imagine you're a professional siege
roster now you finish the season
second last don't have to play a
relegation match
and still have to hand your pro spot
over to a challenger roster
why well because your org has abandoned
you and as per some crazy rules
you're no longer allowed to compete but
here's the best part
the roster that you're handing your pro
spot over to
also doesn't have an orc that's what
happened to eunited
look it's been a long time since i've
seen the siege community
this unanimously disappointed and
honestly
i understand why
okay so before we dive into things
please make sure guys that you like the
video
subscribe to the channel and hop in the
comments to let us know if you
want more siege content just like this
it really helps both the don't at me
team and me specifically
decide what kind of siege content you
guys want to see
okay so in order to understand how all
of this went down we need to go back to
october 30th which is the day that
e-united announced that they would be
dropping
their siege roster thankfully we were
able to speak with the former
coach of the united meepi who helped us
construct a timeline of sorts
now some of what he told us is already
public some not
either way we're going to walk you
through what he told
us happened according to meepi eunite's
decision to back out of siege was made
for a variety of reasons now some of
them had to do with kovid
others to do with ubisoft's handling of
the north american league as a whole
some of them were even left confidential
now apparently after relaying their
decision to ubisoft eunited told their
roster that as long as a new org came
along to purchase the license that
e-united had previously owned
the roster would be able to remain in
the nal the xe united roster then
reached out to ubisoft on october 31st
for support
they asked ubi whether they'd be helping
to move the sale of said license along
and on the same day ooby responded that
they would be working to
quote find xe united a new home
apparently mipi proceeded to reach out
to one of ubisoft's
senior esports representatives in the
hope of getting some concrete
reassurance that
as long as some new org came along to
purchase said license
the xe united boys wouldn't be in peril
of losing their jobs
and from what he told us he received no
answer whatsoever
okay so fast forward to november 5th
which is when rumors began to spread
that xe united were in fact going to
lose their spot
and that everything they'd been told by
both ubisoft and e-united themselves
wasn't true which mipi spoke about on
stream when we first heard these rumors
if we were to believe that they were
true we assumed that
the the eighth place position we were
told that rent free would get promoted
and that um
temple would take our position to
seventh um as that was a rumor we heard
from another team
a week ago a week and a half ago
apparently after hearing said rumors
xe united proceeded to reach out to
ubisoft yet again
through a private official channel and
yet again
received no response whatsoever they
tried the official channel one final
time on november 9th
to no avail only to find that the senior
esports representative that mipi had
previously reached out to
had finally decided to reply claiming
that while ubisoft couldn't tell them
anything as of yet
they'd be in contact soon but they
wouldn't be
not until november 11th that is when
ubisoft unveiled in the aforementioned
private official channel that a blog
post would be going up shortly
explaining
everything 15 minutes later the blog
post goes up
and it's official exe united are jobless
now what do we mean by jobless well as
it turns out
spots in siege's newly formed north
american league
are owned by orgs something which wasn't
true of pro league
so when e-united backed out the roster
who'd previously represented them
lost all claims to the spot they'd
worked so hard to earn what's even
crazier is that they
even lost the chance to play for it you
see according to the league's official
rule book
the departure of a team from the u.s
division automatically places them last
place within the division
this means that the team e-united was
ahead of tempo storm
finished the stage in second last thus
avoiding relegation
what's more for some incomprehensible
reason xe united's disqualification
meant that they wouldn't have to play
the relegation match between the last
placed nal roster and the top seeded
challenger roster
a lineup known as rent free instead ooby
simply
gave the spot to red free not only were
eunited
not actually in last place but ubisoft
didn't even give them the courtesy of
playing the relegation match that the
last seated team is entitled to play
the reason because they weren't
represented by an org
unfortunately rent free being promoted
to the eighth place spot from what i am
aware now keep in mind i'm not aware of
much
means nothing but the fact that they've
come out and just kicked us out the
league
is just the frustrating part
the reason why it's frustrating is
because i've been trying to get
ubisoft to talk to me for the past
couple of weeks just to confirm
that everything that i was told when
united left still stands
here's the truly messed up thing though
rent free
also weren't represented by an org this
means that ooby bounced an nal roster
for not being signed
took away their chance to play for their
pro spot
and just gave it to a challenger league
roster who also wasn't signed
in the hope that some org would just
come along and sign them
like what oh and the truly awful thing
is that most of the xc united guys found
out they were jobless the same way we
did
on twitter i sent emails to very high
positions
and the only response i got was we can't
tell you
we'll tell you soon the next
communication that i got from ubisoft
was
this release what a way to find out
that you've just lost your well you've
just lost your job worst of all
was meepi who as he mentioned on stream
had
just sat down to eat dinner with his
girlfriend i
cooked myself dinner i sat down on the
couch with my girlfriend
we're both eating and i get a text
message
telling asking me what has uberself done
and i'm confused it was especially bad
for rexen who'd also
fallen prey to the luminosity scandal
back in april
this man was cheated out of two pro
spots in the span of just over
six months suffice it to say the siege
community
was pissed casters hosts analysts
community figures competitors and
content creators came out
in droves to express their
dissatisfaction
with ubisoft's handling of the situation
and honestly
i completely understand why i'm sorry
but no matter which way you slice it
this is a
very bad look for ooby the nal
and everyone involved that's not lost on
them apparently
since wei you the director of siege
esports
came out on twitter and addressed
ubisoft's need to
do and be better so where does this
leave
xc united well not in a great spot
as of right now exe united are free
agents
this means that they weren't just
relegated all the way down to challenger
league
they were removed from competition
entirely
if they wanted to reclaim their pro spot
they would have to re-qualify for
challenger
and win it the fairest thing would be
for tempo to play rent free for
relegations and us keep the seventh
place spot that we [ __ ] earned
that we fought for that we played for
that we won there are also some other
unanswered questions like how these
rumors began spreading in the first
place
is it possible that ubisoft began
discussing this with rent free while
keeping
united in the dark if so why
could there be some looming org in the
background and
if so what's stopping them or any org
from
signing x united instead of rent free as
far as i am aware
an organization has to purchase the
license for this for the
basically the eighth place spot now and
then that organization has
free reign to field whichever five
players
they like at the end of the day you
could get an organization that buys the
eighth place spot
and then just picks us up or they can
pick rent free up
or they can pick anybody up
unfortunately
we just don't know which is part of what
makes this whole situation
so crazy it's not clear what fueled this
decision
or whether ubisoft will attempt to
rectify it maybe they'll step in and
reverse the decision
maybe they won't either way when we know
more you will too
imagine you're on a professional siege
roster who finishes
second last doesn't have to play a
relegation match
and still has to hand their pro spot
over to a challenger roster
why why because your orgs abandoned you
that's why
okay so when e-united backed out the
oh my [ __ ] god this is such a rough
shoot this is such a [ __ ] i hate this so
much
ah it's okay it just drives me [ __ ]
crazy man it's such an early shoot and
it's just like
[ __ ] killing me which is part of what
makes this whole situation
so crazy why can't i remember the next
[ __ ] line